hello this is Douglas Darien Walker and
I am joined by my brother Rob and we
both wrote this sketch and we are very
proud of it especially because it's the
first sketch we've done that actually
looks like a real sketch it doesn't look
like you know a couple guys just grabbed
a camera it did something it's actually
looks like a news program wow you
actually look like a real news anchor
yes that's right it doesn't look like a
couple of Schmucks with no HD camera I
can see your shadow though yeah well
that's not real city badge I think you
designed that city that Gotham City uh
yeah actually we undo a small argument
because Don's original backdrop was just
a picture of Chicago and she was still a
it's a picture of Chicago yes it was I'm
just saying it doesn't look like Gotham
City's like what are you talking about
you idiot is Chicago is Gotham City yeah
but they dirtied it up and did all sorts
of things so I sort of added a few
little touches here and there and you
can barely see it but one of the
buildings in the background also says
Wayne on it it's actually very well put
together now we should say how we came
up with this we both saw the Dark Knight
and it gets like everyone else we were
really you know blown away by it and but
we really liked the Joker and we're
trying to think of something we could do
with the Joker but the only problem is
that we're both too vain to shave our
beards so unless we want to go this
season from arrow route we couldn't
really just put makeup over isn't gonna
work so so I just had this idea just it
was just an image of the Joker on the
phone talking to a reporter and that's
it I have nothing else and at first I
think the original idea was to talk
about like you know is the Joker more
you know to do villains get more
publicity than heroes and the Joker was
there to talk about it but then got kind
of weird cuz it's like I think it
brought up that he was being nominated
for an Oscar and stuff and that's like
well wait does the Joker know who he
Fletcher is and although the whole thing
kind of lacks some focus yeah so we
decided to make it a real issue you know
about violence in the media and which of
course I think the Joker could talk
about and then I think I was telling you
this idea and then you have this idea
that Batman calls in and we just start
improvising like what they say what they
would do and we just we just basically
kept riffing off each other until
finally it got down to the whole purple
M&Ms
and then we just broke down laughing
yeah I good I got ya write it down yeah
just a surgeon here bad man say you're
not getting your purple and then it's
choker it's like that I just died yeah
it was you know it's again it's just
this whole sibling rivalry thing it was
just our attempts to one up each other's
lines so you know he would have lying
about you know if he has his own been on
the show I want my trailer and then you
know I said you're not getting a trailer
and then you know I kept adding things
on top of each other and don't find me I
think at some point I said you know and
I want some purple M&Ms and nothing but
purple M&Ms and then Batman says you not
getting your purple M&Ms Joker I think
sibling rivalry attitude is a very good
way to create good writing cuz you're
constantly trying to one-up each other
and that way you can't keep getting
funnier lines so tattoo I think we had
to do work pretty well whenever we try
to write and you think is it just sort
of ends up in the sketch you need the
hole you suck bit we just do you know
they just do that naturally there
there's no writing there it's just I
think it's some way we just got into an
argument and we always just say you suck
no you say no you suck you might find
that if it's immature for us it's
immature for Batman and the Joker which
means it works you know I love you
here's these two epic characters you
know just resorting to you know like be
children just yelling you suck at each
other it sort of just completely
demystifies the mythos and the the
little scrolling at the bottom who did
they for repair
I have no idea but whoever they are
they're a genius yeah yeah Robin
obviously wrote that yeah and it was
kind of a it was kind of held because it
scrolled okay but then we had to fit in
because a lot of jokes match up we had
to with what's going on it was a pain in
the ass to match those up it took I was
like a whole night it was it was
bargaining it took like eight hours and
I kept yelling at our producer Fargo is
trying to show us how to do this because
we have to break this up into a million
itty-bitty pieces and I was just like
Bargo there has to be an easier way to
do this and he insisted there wasn't and
we took like eight hours doing this all
day and then that's when I got come in
and Doug's like guess what Rob and I'm
like let me guess there was an easier
way to do it he's like yes tonight five
seconds
now Fargo for those who don't know he's
also the the Harvard teachers in this
Morales Racha which could be a very
racist name we don't know he seemed to
be okay with it so it's a thing I just
was just like well he's he's the moral
center of the show so Cohen Morales
which is a Spanish name was Spanish last
name I'm pretty sure but yeah but but
then he's Indian so I just went Raja so
it's like the stupidest name yeah well
I'll tell you the fine thing too is that
every time we use Barga we've come to
the conclusion he's kindly Christopher
Walken and they he's not like a
phenomenal act or anything but he's very
entertaining to watch and he gives us
the greatest bloopers his bloopers are
just hilarious mostly because he doesn't
memorize any of his lung no he comes in
he has no idea when he's gonna say which
just it just makes it all the more fun
Ian's how many play what else laughs
Adam whenever we whenever they watch art
stuff by me I just crack up every time
he's on screen I think he has a tendency
to go totally William Shatner on us too
which is pretty funny and just so you
know people are wondering we are gonna
do more glory Prince if one is an out at
you by the time you give this commentary
and they'll definitely be more Joker and
Batman impressions done poorly by us
yeah well the interesting thing about
this sketch is its its own thing but I
think what we had in mind was something
along the lines of a big SNL sketch a
big Daily Show sort of sketch I mean I
think in some ways this is based on
there was an old sketch on SNL about
Court TV as it goes nothing like a
Ghostbuster line yeah they'd be a
running joke it's always gonna be a
Ghostbuster line that every Laurie
sketch this is true we were pressed for
something to say we couldn't think of
anything so but I think a lot of us
based on an Old Court TV sketch where
they were interviewing scooby-doo and we
just liked the idea of interviewing
cartoon yeah sure it's kind of like that
just expection on characters so that's
about it hope you enjoyed bye bye bye